when we last spoke to you said you had
suits ready for an opportunity and you
didn't know what was before I was for a
GT it was this you see the suits are
ready he's just one of them this was
definitely what I mean this is
definitely one of you got to get ready
before it comes and I had to study the
cummerbund ready to go I mean the white
tie all the stuff I said man I'm gonna
put on my best because this deserves the
best
[Applause]
that's so much fun doing this did you
this is let me tell you something is a
dream come true for me because I'm a
tell you story it's why when I was a kid
I'm gonna wrap you quick no just oh no
no my mother wouldn't let me perform in
the talent show when I was in high
school Wow because she was very
religious but I begged her could I host
it and she let me host it and this goes
full circle it's like oh my god you know
thirty years later Here I am on the
number one talent show in the world and
I'm hosting you know well if Tyra
doesn't come back for AGT during the
summer are you down I'm so listen they
had me at hello
okay okay I'm telling you that right now
congratulations I'm last man I can't
[Music]